salve
buonasera buonasera a tutti io sono
marianna stasera vi racconterò una
storia la mia storia e la mia piccola
storia
e allora quando ho parlato cioè quando
abbiamo iniziato a pensare al quando me
l'ha detto qual era il tema del di
quest'anno del teddy che era
contaminazione più che un po in giro
anche i miei amici
secondo voi che cos'è la contaminazione
loro mano ovviamente dato un significato
negativo la contaminazione può essere
contaminazione macchiare insozzare le
arpie ad esempio contaminavano ogni
luogo sul quale si posavano oppure
foscolo dice né gli incensi avvolto dei
cadaveri letto e supplicanti contaminò
quindi infettano ma c'è anche un altro
senso che possiamo dare alla
contaminazione può essere anche una
contaminazione di idee ci può essere sì
possiamo anche essere infettati da un
idea che possa essere comunque un'idea
positiva per noi
io vengo dalla periferia dalla periferia
nord di napoli da da scampia e mi sono
sempre chiesta cosa mi ha contaminato il
luogo da cui vengo io a differenza degli
altri speaker
come ho detto all'inizio vi racconterò
la mia piccola storia che diversa
ovviamente da dalle altre perché io sono
rimasta sul territorio un po per
necessità un po per scelta poi dopo
allora la prima de positiva e late
positiva del dell'italia vista dal dallo
spazio ed è una cosa affascinante è come
se noi ci sentissimo piccoli facciamo
parte di un
un gioco che è molto affascinante mi
sono sempre vista me le persone che amo
come se fossimo delle parabole che
veniamo sparate praticamente in alto e
abbiamo una nostra taglia traiettoria la
nostra traiettoria in meccanica celeste
viene chiamata orbita con eccentricità
ora questo orbita viene chiamata orbita
di fuga se si allontana dall origine ma
se invece tutto il contrario questo
orbita va si avvicina all'oggetto viene
chiamata orbita di cattura la mia orbita
di cattura è questa qua e il posto da
dove vengo
la cultura è l'unica arma di riscatto
ed è per me un messaggio insomma
positivo che mi ha veramente
condizionata
io vengo dalla periferia come ho detto
prima da una periferia difficile di
napoli ma preferì a scampia
la fotografia è di davide cerullo che è
un altro personaggio che venera scampia
in una persona che è rimasta a scampia
per lottare quando e andava in città
perché ho studiato al centro storico a
napoli quando andava anche
all'università quando gli dicevo che io
venivo dalla periferia e venivo da quel
tipo di periferia
mi guardavano tutti un posto fortore
dicevano non è possibile che tu venga da
quel posto
forse perché magari nell'immaginario
tutti hanno un'idea che chi viene da
quel posto è una persona cosa un po
difficile un po
caratterizzata magari da letto piuttosto
che da un profumo un una cosa simpatica
che mi hanno sempre raccontato i miei
fratelli
la mia famiglia è sempre un aneddoto
simpatico
loro dicevano agli altri che non
venivano da la periferia
loro venivano dalla 167 cioè dalla 167
dalle case popolari come se dissociando
i numeri si desse un significato
differente al posto dove venivamo i miei
genitori sono stati per me un punto
fondamentale veramente per tutti il
samente i miei genitori non sono andati
a scuola
mio padre ha vissuto il dopoguerra
quindi non ha potuto studiare non ha
avuto la possibilità di studiare ha
preso praticamente alla terza media non
ha fatto il militare quindi figuratevi
mi ha sempre detto leggi studia che è
fondamentale e importante perché lui
sapeva cosa significava una persona per
me importante bambino un insegnante una
penna e un libro possono cambiare il
mondo
ed è vero io ogni volta che passeggio
per scampia
mi ritrovo questi messaggi in un uomo
che ha cambiato la mia vita è stato
hermann hesse e il primo libro che ho
letto ed hernanes e non è stato si
tratta come un po hanno fatto tutti no
il mio primo libro è stato demian e
neanche a farlo apposta demian è stata
la mia prima casa editrice quindi è
stato proprio un sogno ho avuto molti
amici che sono andati via che hanno
lasciato questo posto sono andati
all'estero hanno preso contatto con
altre culture giustamente con altre
lingue
anche io volevo farlo io volevo
diventare una giornalista
volevo scrivere della gente volevo
scrivere delle persone che vivevano in
quel posto
però purtroppo a vent'anni ho perso nei
genitori e questo dà letteralmente
gambizzato a vent'anni residente potenti
ci si sente capaci veramente di spaccare
il mondo
invece a me l'hanno fatto rimanere la
allora in quel momento mi sono detta ma
che devo fare
vado cammino ma del mezzo alla gente
non posso fermarmi devo capire cos'è
questo posto ma devo capire soprattutto
chi sono le persone che stanno in questo
posto secondo me oggi restare è un atto
rivoluzionario è molto più facile
partire che rimanere ma rimanere
soprattutto in questi luoghi difficili
dove comunque sono cresciuta perché c'è
questa idea
si parte come ho detto anche prima per
conoscere il mondo per conoscere altre
culture
si ritorna per conoscere se stessi e per
conoscere le radici dove siamo e chi con
coach hanno fatto crescere ci hanno
contaminato
ovviamente io ho fatto il percorso
inverso come le parabole di cui vi
parlavo prima
non ho guardato verso l'alto guardato
verso il basso
sono scesa giù sono nata dalle persone
nello strato sociale e come ho detto
prima io sono rimasta perché mi sono
detta se io impianto un seme nella testa
delle persone che vivono questo posto
devo fare in modo di rinvigorirlo
proprio come un fiore nel cemento quindi
dare forza a rinvigorire le persone che
come me i ragazzi che come me sono
rimasti in quel posto e ovviamente mi
sono detta come posso fare
cioè come fuggi ok se scrivo benissimo
poi mia cugina mi ha detto facciamo una
cosa io un'idea tutte donne
prendiamo le donne del quartiere
facciamo ma radio facciamo una radio e
radio skai radio scampia radio scampia è
un sogno è una passione che noi portiamo
avanti e la piattaforma interattiva che
interagisce di più dove io abito
dell'abitato e la piattaforma che dà
voce ed anche un mezzo alle persone che
abitano quel posto di parlare di farsi
sentire di riappropriarsi dei propri
spazi degli spazi territoriali che ci
sono lì perché questo è importante e
importante che ci sia la possibilità di
riappropriarsi della voce e che ci sia
qualcuno che ascolti e che faccia che
faccia marciare queste persone oltre a
questo mi sono detta cosa posso fare di
più quando si entra in contatto con le
persone che vivono quel posto persone
difficili persone che hanno ovviamente
figli mariti in galera
c'è un altra parte ci sono le vittime
che vivono ancora in quei posti sono le
vittime della camorra e io con un mio
carissimo amico diego somma rita vico
sommaripa e anche un'altra mia carissima
anche un altro mio carissimo amico che
amo profondamente che fabio pisano ci
siamo detti a cosa possiamo fare quindi
parliamo di quello che sta accadendo
parliamo anche delle vittime che ci sono
lì e che vogliono continuare e rimangono
in quel posto e vogliono lottare e
quindi è nato nel campo delle viole
questa la fotografia di claude in krones
guardate come bella guardate che grazia
intorno a queste mani sbucciate no un
putt alla violenza
che c'è in quei luoghi guardate la
grazia del fiore
nonostante la difficoltà e le sofferenze
che può dare quel luogo e io lo so l'ho
vissuto lo vivo se prima
purtroppo gli eventi mi hanno fatto
rimanere in quel posto e oggi lo scelgo
quel posto io ci voglio rimanere perchè
voglio lottare e la soddisfazione più
grande secondo me sarà pari a tutte le
sofferenze che ho patito che comunque
anche altre persone patiscono per questo
io parlo anche del contagio che può
avere il posto in cui vivi per
l'individuo ok individuo parola tutti
siamo degli individui però purtroppo a
me è capitato spesso di potrai pure
soprammobili mandato di fatto quindi non
posso dimenticare veramente quello che
mi hanno detto sempre miei genitori
leggi e io voglio leggervi l'ultima cosa
una poesia che per me è importantissima
che scusate la memoria molto a memoria a
breve termine la bellissima quindi
dovuta a scrivere lo potrà imparare a
memoria ed è una poesia di neruda e dice
è proibito è previso piangere senza
imparare svegliarti la mattina senza
sapere che fare avere paura dei tuoi
ricordi e per vito non sorridere ai
problemi non lottare per quello in cui
credi e desistere per paura non cercare
di trasformare i tuoi sogni in realtà è
proibito non dimostrare il tuo amore far
pagare agli altri i tuoi malumori e
proibito abbandonare i tuoi amici non
cercare di comprendere coloro che ti
stanno accanto e chiamarli solo quando
ne ha bisogno e per vito non essere te
stesso davanti alla gente
fingere davanti alle persone che non ti
interessa
essere gentile solo con chi si ricorda
di te dimenticare tutti coloro che ti
amano e per vito non fare le cose per te
stesso avere paura della vita dei suoi
compromessi non vivere ogni giorno come
se fosse il tuo ultimo respiro è
proibito sentire la mancanza di qualcuno
senza gioire dimenticare i suoi occhi e
le sue risate solo perché le vostre
strade hanno smesso di abbracciarsi
dimenticare il passato e farlo scontare
al presente è proibito non cercare di
comprendere le persone pensare che le
loro vite valgono meno della tua non
credere che ciascuno tiene il proprio
cammino nelle proprie mani e proibito
non creare la tua storia non avere
neanche un momento per la gente che ha
bisogno di te non comprendere che ciò
che la vita ti dona allo stesso modo te
lo può togliere è proibito non cercare
la tua felicità non vivere la tua vita
pensando positivo non pensare che
possiamo solo migliorare
non sentire che senza di te posso mondo
non sarebbe lo stesso non sentire che
senza di te questo mondo non sarebbe più
lo stesso e vi saluto dicendo che di
solito mio carissimo amico non so se
conoscete pure voi lello si chiama dice
chi parte sala cosa fugge ma non sa che
cosa circa grazie